[Music]
in how to prison news submitted by what
is love what is love Lori Loughlin has
hired a prison coach to get her ready
for jail so true there's prison coaches
I wonder if it's like a guy named
Chronicle Jesse's wife is going away
oh that's university [ __ ] she
she paid to get her kids in there oh it
was her that did hurt me Huffman oh I
heard about Felicity Huffman I didn't
hear about her listen he pled guilty
went to jail for like three days and
this [ __ ] is probably going away for
years why why she didn't plead guilty
but she also did worse [ __ ] she did she
paid like over five hundred thousand
dollars for her two daughters to be fake
crew members they photoshopped them on
in row and boat yeah but guess for what
school what school would you think is
worth five hundred fifty Harvard right
USC bro what no shade on USC I won my
comic got straight FS in high school got
to went to USC can we [ __ ] on a let me
get cuz she didn't get into USC though
[Music]
good job dude I thought if you have
money you can get into USC yeah that's
not my kind of did it it's the
University of response how they
workshops well she went to Community
College at like Santa Monica or whatever
and then she was able to transfer there
but still like she got like D's and F's
at high school Wow
500k yeah so that's the whole backstory
on why we're even talking why she's
going to prison or like she could be
preparing to go to prison or whatever so
who's the prison coach I don't know I
know I don't know who it is I wanted a
tattooed face guy named like yeah shy
girl creeper or whatever it's a straight
cholo
it's like Kenan Thompson's character in
SNL or some [ __ ] the scared straight guy
that's true but okay none of you guys
know what Steve's talking about you guys
don't watch SNL anymore nobody does but
they apparently say why yeah then why
bring up the bid what no I should know
your crowd I never watched it I was
always a MADtv guy yeah I watched both
back in the day but you could watch both
true it was still good because MADtv
came on right before us I know so you
could watch both you could watch like 30
minutes imagine TV before before there
was Internet videos and you could wait
till whatever time you wanted to watch
things that's what I do right alright so
the story here is that it's been
reported by an insider that she's
knuckle lean down learning the lingo and
practicing martial arts to give off the
impression she's tough and to ward off
potential bullies they're all just gonna
be your fans she should be learning
because like all you ain't [ __ ] in here
now that's exactly what you should be
learning how to eat [ __ ] frankly that's
true maybe that's what the coach is
teaching that be good yeah
so this prison consults him for Fox
named John fuller for [ __ ] fuller yeah
so he was saying that whoever she hired
is giving her the best I mean the worst
advice ever because by teaching her to
be on the defense they're already
preparing her yeah it's already [ __ ]
up she should have came to me and karate
yep find the baddest [ __ ] there and
give her your puss on sit you gotta slow
build that [ __ ] to you don't [ __ ]
just go in there start stabbing it with
your tongue you gotta walk around and
hold her put pop tell you oh you gotta
[ __ ] slow it down like you're Stern
suit just very slow right use it hot oh
no how about this it's like your Stern
feet biting me bro
juju Jim it's like you sure chunky beef
so you give it a good stuff right now
it's true
chunky beef you love him bro that's why
and then what baby dip the ladle dip dip
dip the label test it
yeah that's some good soup right there
this laughing is good and you tie it on
anything show you got put in microwave
all right
so fuller like I'm talking about he
noted that when a Brazilian jiu-jitsu
professor who was jailed and this is no
or raping and killing his one-year-old
son he was reportedly gang raped
repeatedly for good unless he was
innocent
oh yeah no no there's there's photos of
it his whole [ __ ] pajamas his jab
pajama it's full of cockeyed [ __ ] and
piss and everything cuz it's just so
nasty wait because he's nastier because
they rape those hey hey hey peddle
rapers in jail they [ __ ] hate so the
reason why this [ __ ] prison consultants
it says this is because it's like dude
he specialized in martial arts and look
what happened to him yeah you know like
he can't specialize on five guys holding
him down one guys banging his head over
rapists murderers person yeah that's
though probably the worst of the worst I
hope he wasn't innocent and that's what
I said I hope he wasn't I hope it was
for sure guilty yeah I hope it was
innocent nothing happen in that one year
old well it did no idea yeah the
conclusion happened but you know anyway
remember Oh God mm-hmm so anyways for
the jujitsu professors just move on
please please
he must I'm trying to be positive here
goddammit New Year's resolution ten
present consultant also man go way were
sensitive in Europe briefing consultant
brought up Martha Stewart
so she's Cyril five months back in 2004
at the prison camp in West Virginia at
the beach which is like a nice hotel
right so then they're saying like we
don't know where she's gonna go where
the Laurie Lawson's gonna go what she
goes in there fights other celebrities
and [ __ ] in jail
I learned [ __ ] jujitsu and [ __ ]
boxing and I gotta use it now but the
whole point of bringing her up though is
to make a point that she made friends
when she was incarcerated she even
visited them after she was released and
that's because there was a different
approach
Martha Keith yeah with Martha because he
said that she approached it oh that the
object of being respected is to not
disrespect so then like Martha you know
yeah you walk in trying to be a tough
person they're gonna [ __ ] eat your
place so then that's why this if I'm
making everyone's beds - it was like
tree decorating their shelter oh we love
this person - it's not so good or just
like you'll be chilled me when I get out
I'll give you [ __ ] a hundred grand
but Martha went in for a cool bar I'm
what's the yeah so she went it was like
some she was lying to federal agents
investigating insider trading way cool
yeah it's pretty it's pretty cool maybe
and she got caught like smoking weed and
all kinds of [ __ ]
Snoop Dogg [ __ ] right-hand man I love
it dude the celebrities in jail should
be a reality show and they could call it
celebrity I can't believe it no you
can't America loves it the concepts type
of the title sucks
this is your reality show on Becky
called fool jailhouse okay well
workshopping this job if you go in if
you go in to jail for insider trading do
a bunch of white-collar banker guys hold
you down and start kissing on the foot
thank you like that good job like you're
welcome
you did good because in this case it's I
don't know if she'll go to like full-on
jail jail well okay so then this guy
thing that he's saying if she ends up
accepting responsibility she will likely
face less than 18 months in prison
prison in prison yeah but um but
initially you know she ended up saying
that she was innocent and then if she
still continues claiming to be innocent
and then this goes to trial then she has
to actually prove that she unknowingly
donated $500,000 an accident a charity
that's bogus if she has good lawyers she
has to prove to the guy contr which is
what she said that's her defense right
so right now because she didn't plead
guilty she's probably in for a harsh
sentence like exactly if she's proven
guilty
yes but it's looking her case Subspace
exactly so it's looking like she's going
to jail solar's you got a guy who's
gonna her lawyers suck well we don't
know she's basically it's a fail-safe
right she's like if I go away I want to
be ready for the [ __ ] I see you're also
saying so her team are saying that the
prosecutors have been hiding evidence
that they have on her and which I guess
is not something you do during its it's
exculpatory evidence which proves that
you might be innocent right there's
evidence that shows that you might not
be guilty and so they're saying that the
prosecutors are withholding that
evidence just happen before it's not
crazy right so then that's why she like
her adviser said yeah just say you're
not going because of me because of this
possible I see you might we might be
able get you off basically right
people always say don't take the first
deal in a criminal case well and three
days or some both have different charges
against them so it's like yeah even
though they were caught for the same
crime one might have like 10 counts of
murder while the other one is like
assisted or some sort at the end of the
day it still wouldn't have been nearly
as bad if she just said yo I'm guilty in
the beginning maybe she was trying to
avoid going on her record or something I
think that these rich people cuz I
record it she still could get a job
though it's okay these rich people are
obsessed with where their kids go to
school because that's where their
friends who they all hang out these rich
[ __ ] circles and get breakfast
together and [ __ ] and dinners they
almost like a Chinese family they brag
about the exactly they brag about where
their kids are going and that gives them
like self esteem yeah and so I think
that her lived through their children
that's all unaccomplished these [ __ ]
are guilty and being and being guilty
right that makes her image look back to
her friends social circle so she's like
no no innocent innocent is and I think
that that hubris is what's gonna end up
being heard on [ __ ] hubris mm-hmm
damn you know what that is yep that's
when I just realized you
bro I'm sorry evidence it's that you you
think you've got all the answers you
think you got this [ __ ] that's you don't
like five big words that he says like
hubris abscond there's a couple that he
says repeated I say accoutrements oh
yeah I mean it's a croissant that's
inside-out I think goes inside yeah so
vexes prison consultant guy he ends up
saying that there is certain there are
certain prison etiquette that you can't
ignore for example if you just sit on
someone's bed to tie your shoe that
complete invitation for sexual
advancement in prison oh [ __ ] is that
what you thought of me Steve close the
door yeah shoes like right well I don't
think I'm a suicide boarder Oh true what
was the pleasure the toilet oh yeah that
they do like a courtesy flush no were
like you know buddy I didn't want to
bring it up cuz he's was really good I
fill a prison etiquette thing they
should have no shoes in prison
well like I feel like they could
strangle someone else with this yes so
they shouldn't have a velcro shoes yeah
or do they that's all I know about
prison is from um orange is the new
black and is completely fiction I mean
not fiction but it's like they make it
more make it fine they make it more fun
thing sound like a summer camp and I'm
like I want to go to prison
they don't use right now cuz it's too
loud he [ __ ] goes to jail like it's
air B & Bs and he told me that your
friend
yeah well he's peeping into a lot of
different jails within California he's
like do you think Nashville is better
I need o me the the prison culture is
different for region as well oh so like
some like he's like la is pretty [ __ ]
violent and then yeah and there's like
no Lake out and yet there's like the
prison prison where there's like life
sentence people and stuff like that
like death row is pretty nice yeah I
heard you didn't go there but yeah cuz
everyone's more chill like some some
people trying to get on death row so
they could have a better living
environment yeah yeah bring Canadian
prison they're like good morning
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]